they crush fallen leaves with their feet
and recycle old exercise books these
children live in an orphanage near the
capital cat rendu old materials are
transformed into new the concept isn't
exactly high-tech but its innovative the
orphanage makes its own biomass
briquettes the facility is funded by
private donations and can't afford wood
for heating Suresh Conte is the
orphanage director we need a lot of
money to buy food and to buy three it
just like a waste of money tree and wood
and so we were searching for a new
substitutes of a wood and it's not just
about saving money it's also about
saving the nearby forests a local brick
factory is consuming wood supplies at a
furious pace and whorin more land is
being used for farming in the last 25
years Nepal is lost about one quarter of
its forest land the orphanage house is
nearly 60 children near mana and Sudesh
county care for them as best they can on
the orphanage roof there's a makeshift
chute for water collection and two solar
thermal units for heating it to solar
cell modules were installed recently the
older children at the orphanage say that
was a big improvement
that's Kerala for another now we can
read at night and now we can watch TV
get it DB area now just a mother good
the biomass briquettes won't replace
wood here as a source of fuel but they
provide enough heat for two small
cooking stoves the briquettes generate
more heat and less smoke than a similar
amount of wood robux father is dead now
and his mother is too poor to take care
of the child so he came to the orphanage
Suresh and Nirmala have become his
adoptive parents Wow I try to be like a
mother to these children I do everything
I can to show them a mother's love in
the past power outages often kept the
children from finishing their school
work after classes but now a solar
energy keeps the lamps lit they run on
power that's stored in batteries during
the course of the day when there is no
electricity we we read on candle now now
here is solar light we always studies
the children at the orphanage are taking
advantage of modern technology to help
improve their lives but they're also
doing more than that they're also
working together to help save the
environment